my friends I'm Alana and welcome to my
channel today we're gonna be talking
about Game of Thrones Season eight I'm
also just playing h2 on a hunts
difficulty because why not do both so of
course people have seen my stance
publicly on Twitter and podcasts and
stuff like that I am in the camp of
people who doesn't like Game of Thrones
and I got a very angry tweet from
someone
well I won't raise any amount but the
gist of it if you take out the swearing
is his Game of Thrones Season 8 really
that bad but ultimately yes
pull me Game of Thrones Season eight was
was bad and I think it's bad because it
went from being a show that I thought
was truly fantastic to something that I
didn't care about and obviously having
that comparison is why it hurts so much
for people it's because you knew what it
was and you lost that but my biggest
criticism of the season and I think the
overall wrap up of my opinion is that it
ended up focusing on being impressive or
having big set pieces rather than being
meaningful and I personally like the
show of being meaningful of course
people who like the latest seasons
you're totally justified in liking those
big set pieces and the spectacles and
that stuff is fun but to give an example
Jaime Lannister knighting Brienne was a
really nice thing to happen that was a
very good arc that he has been walking
on for the full eight seasons this
Redemption off where we see Jaime do the
worst thing possible very early on that
really affected a lot of things that
happen in the show obviously talking
about bran and then in season eight we
have him being nice to Brienne she's
suspicious of it and then finally she
lets her guard down and lets him in and
that resulted in a sweet relationship
that I bought because Jamie's Ark had
been heading in that direction for so
long for them to just snap next episode
and have none of that mean anything I
understand that there are people saying
oh but Jaime was always like that so he
was always his weakness he always left
so I get why you would say that but that
doesn't mean that as a viewer it has
meaning to me it does not have a
positive impact on me it does not make
me feel something I understand how you
justify it that doesn't mean I like it
and I don't think that means it's good
writings I think it's actually harder to
get Jaime to go through a full
Redemption Hawk after we know how much
she was in love with Cersei and how much
he did for her jump to the Battle of
Winterfell my biggest criticism of this
was not just that characters weren't
dying of course we wanted characters to
die because when you lose people you
know this does wait too
everyone else the other characters have
to react there is more emotional
conflict in the air and that that stuff
is enticing to watch as a viewer but my
biggest complaint is that they set
people up in ways that it seemed like
they would definitely die and then they
would just cut away
you were like oh how are they gonna get
out of this one how is he gonna live
Sam's on the ground piles of bodies
around him how on earth is he going to
get away and then the camera just cuts
the issue wasn't that nobody died and
that the show was subverting
expectations it was actually that by
choosing to not show us how those
characters get out of those situations
the show is lazily asking us to connect
dots but it didn't do the heavy lifting
to draw the dots close enough together
so that we could do that an all-night
King thing I get why everyone was
disappointed by that that didn't bother
me as much I looked at the night King as
a example of like here's what happens if
we all actually ban together we all work
towards the same cause we can actually
accomplish this look at us go and then
the snap to everyone reverting to caring
about the throne again I think is a
message that I find interesting so while
yes it felt weird to have it build up
for so long to be the whole main villain
of the show I didn't mind the outcome of
that but how they got there did bother
you build up this villain that we're all
excited about and invested in whatever
else and then you don't explain any of
his motives so we learn in season 8 that
I guess the night King really wants
brand he wants to find bran doesn't tell
us why doesn't tell us why that's his
motive so why would you build up this
villain for such a long time and then
result in him meaning nothing but also
you know we don't have any more
understanding of him after that episode
and I think that's what really
disappointed people and then of course
Arya sneaking up on the night King I
mean everyone's saying she's a monster
SAS and of course she could do that and
I understand that logic why have a Havas
watch all the training of her becoming a
faceless man and wearing the mosques if
you're not going to show us that when
she's facing the most important villain
of the entire
one of the cool things about Aria is how
she got those abilities so why would you
never show them to us even in the area
where she's like failing to get through
a library full of zombies and then she
can sneak up on the knight King it just
doesn't it doesn't add up unfortunately
in a way that that it takes away the
satisfaction of her actions I think is
the biggest issue that I have again
again a lot of my criticism here is that
the issue is not what actually happened
it's the way that it happens her killing
the knight king absolutely makes sense
to me the way that she did it they
didn't even try to make it make sense
and of course during that episode you
know there were a lot of people making
fun of not knowing what bran was doing
why he was being so useless we're gonna
end up appointing a king yeah he was
super helpful in that fight thanks brand
I think in a lot of seasons frankly bran
himself causes a lot of issues where
previously he was interesting and
mysterious he was like a dr. Manhattan
figure I could understand that I think
that by revealing at the end of the show
that he can tell the future by saying
why do you think I came all this way
that causes a lot of problems for the
rest of the show and frankly kind of
undoes a lot of that careful
storytelling up to that point it makes
it seem like he plotted this whole thing
to rule and being the three-eyed Raven
couldn't he just be alive for 3,000
years and be a dictator anyway it
doesn't it doesn't answer any questions
about what's going to happen to the
people that we care about when the show
ends and I think that one of my favorite
fantasy novels that I've been reading
for a really long time that's an
important thing is that you want to know
what the off the map of the thing is
that's what makes an end ending feel
satisfying to me I think so to jump back
a little bit let's talk about the
Dothraki dying in the Battle of
Winterfell obviously that was a huge
deal that meant it felt like they made
it feel like there were very big stakes
to that battle but things were going
down things were going wrong not
everyone was gonna make it out alive at
the end of this show and of course a lot
of people did end up dying but bringing
them back three episodes later with no
explanation the issue isn't that I don't
like that they didn't explain it of
course that's a problem that I think
that they really should have filled in
the gaps there but I think that they
were trying to do it as a big plot twist
again so it cares about spectacle more
than substance in the end the issue that
I have with it is that it erased all the
stakes so by having something that seems
you see
and does that mean nothing you kind of
just stopped caring about other things
that meant that in the battle for the
Red Keep and everything going on at
King's Landing
I I knew that nothing necessarily meant
anything so how am I supposed to be
invested very very very similarly I mean
Daenerys forgetting about your ensuite
is wholly shoo-bop its own but then a
single scorpion kills a single scorpion
kills a single dragon but then she gets
to King's Landing and there are tons of
scorpions and they can't kill a single
dragon so I think I said before but I do
like Daenerys being the man queen I like
that as a twist I'm into it it makes
sense to me I think it's exciting but at
that point definitely not enough had
happened that we would picture her doing
that and I think that that is a really
good example of how the show became
different from previous seasons and that
we used to see a lot of stuff from
characters perspectives and understand
what they were going through with this
we didn't really see a lot of how
danaerys was actually feeling because
they didn't flush them out I don't know
maybe they didn't have time but we
didn't see how she was feeling all we
saw was a snap I think to me it
ultimately became a thing that was
Daenerys was killing innocence because
the showrunners needed us to know that
she was evil and see her as a villain
rather than because she as Daenerys as a
character would do that they did it for
the audience not for Daenerys or not for
anyone else in the show and again that's
that's my crux here that's where it
really loses me because of this shift I
didn't care I didn't cry when Jamie died
I wasn't upset I didn't feel any snake
once he died she was only on screen for
25 minutes the whole season and barely
said a word when John was sent back to
the wall I didn't care when Daenerys
tone evil I didn't care it just because
it was about set-pieces and glory and
explosions it meant that caring about
the individual characters became a lot
harder and that's so disappointing when
I used to care so so so much there was a
point where I wanted Joffrey today more
badly than I've ever wanted any other
fictional character to die and I'm sure
a lot of you would be on board there
with me that didn't happen for Cersei at
the end of the show even though she did
have several seasons to build her up as
a villain but she just didn't seem to do
anything at the end of the show and I
mean the one person who did make some
calls at the end of the show
who's a prisoner it doesn't make sense
why he chose brand but we're just trying
to ignore that one just trying to forget
about it i think you know i could give
more examples but i'm sure you get the
idea and and what my biggest criticisms
are and how i think that those
criticisms are consistent throughout a
lot of the characters maybe aside from
Sansa I feel like she's the one
character that I feel like really had an
arc and I understood what she wanted and
why she wanted it what the hell is that
oh that thing moves it is the fact that
I don't care that that bothers me and
yeah hopefully this this explains it
pretty well because again I understand
why other people don't feel this way I
get that if you like the spectacle you
like the spectacle that's just not what
I like Game of Thrones for and why this
season to me felt like a really big
letdown that's even boring some of those
plot holes that exists like the white
horse or why did John go to the wall
when there's no one to protect Westeros
problem so hopefully that makes sense
and hopefully I was able to be coherent
while playing this very violent video
game on the hardest difficulty alright
I'm a lotta and I will see you guys next
time lovely